good citizens of the reject Nation I
hope you are doing well and you asked
for it so now it is time to rank phase
four and we are going to include the
Guardians the Galaxy holiday special is
that part of phase four I don't know
they said the end was wakanda forever
but then immediately after the guardian
of the galaxy had a holiday special so
for the purposes of this list we're
including obviously both of those we're
going all the way back to One Division
all the way through the Guardians
holiday special now I am very excited
for this list in particular that's
because of you because you asked for
this so please leave a comment let me
know what else you want to see leave a
like so this video does well enough I
can keep making these share this with
your friends argue in the comments which
ones do you like rank them yourself let
me know which things I got wrong in your
opinion and remember that opinions are
literally just that this is my journey
with these films and TV shows also if
you like my journey follow me on Tick
Tock where I got 15 seconds 30 seconds
one minute reviews all sorts of stuff
all sorts of data all sorts of trivia
all sorts of goodness over on my Tick
Tock please do check that out and that
is gonna do it it so sit down strap in
let's rank them
[Music]
how much heat from heat first because I
know how much people disliked some
properties and I feel like this is a
nice neutral but I'm always going to be
honest with you and always go with my
experience this is my lowest ranked
phase four and that is what if I
personally and I've said it before and
I'll say it again in brief did not
connect with what if as much as I'd like
to it never felt like it had the stakes
that other MCU properties had it never
for me felt like it was impacting the
greater Marvel Cinematic Universe and I
know that's a good thing sometimes I
like when things are Bubble episodes but
that's when they're consciously bubble
episodes this felt like it was both
trying to be its own thing and a shared
thing and that for me just didn't work I
loved some of the segments in this I
think Ultron in this is actually better
than he is in Age of Ultron I think
certain elements of this are actually
stronger than their live-action
counterparts I think the biggest flaw
here is that when I watch Multiverse
Madness I was like I don't know if this
Multiverse is really part of the what if
thing and I kept thinking that I kept
feeling like a little devalue now by no
means is this my lowest of the greater
MCU it just happens to my lowest of
phase four and I will completely own
that is in part because I struggle to
connect with animation the medium of
Animation is something I'm working on
being able to connect to and this is my
own fatal flaw and I accept that but it
is my lowest that's just my personal
opinion all right keeping it spicy and
this is going to be a lot of you coming
at me and saying like oh he changed his
mind or oh blah blah blah guys the thing
about art and the thing about opinions
is upon rewatch things do change and
I've been thinking about it since it
came out and I've decided to move this
down a number of pegs I think Thor love
and thunder is my second to lowest the
more I go into it it has a lot of the
things that I struggle with in the MCU
and it's it's also kind of tied with my
next one where it devalues the
characters a bit and when you've got
something as beautiful and interwoven as
the tapestry that is the MCU when one
property is bad in the traditional sense
of like maybe it's boring maybe it's it
doesn't deliver in a certain emotional
way that's one thing but when
something's bad in the sense of it
undermines or it devalues or it makes
you feel like the characters are lesser
that's going to be some points against
it in a major way so Thor love and
thunder I do feel like undermined Thor's
Integrity a bit I do feel like it
misused Gore the god butcher when he was
there I dug him but they didn't know God
butchering and I do feel like the the
tonality between comedy and drama was
really disparate and it didn't feel like
it got to connect in a way that I wanted
it to when it was drama I actually
really enjoyed this film and I think
that's honestly when I reviewed it in
relation to the greater MCU I was
thinking of all the dramatic scenes I
was thinking about the last five minutes
which I really enjoy in standby I love
Thor as a father I love the importance
of the the gods being what they are in
this universe and the the deal Christian
Bell had made I still stand by all of
those things but other than the goats a
lot of the comedy fell flat for me and
now that we've seen more and more
releases of deleted scenes and what this
movie could have been and now that we've
seen the five different versions of
Hercules it definitely feels like a
movie that was was put together in post
and I can't put it higher than this spot
so Thor 11 Thunder has uh dropped a bit
for me the more it's been out next
to you that I do also feel kind of
undermines some characters but is a ride
now if this ironically was a what if
it'd probably be in the top ten
unfortunately it is not a what if it is
part of MCU Canon and it doesn't feel
like it understood what came before it
in a way that was honest to the
characters and that is Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness uh I know this
is pretty low and I'm gonna you know
obviously get to my experience with
these other things but I love what Sam
Rainey sets out to make and I love the
genius of Sam raimi's mind but when you
go from and I've said this before I feel
like we got one through seven of the ten
moment Arc of Scarlet Witch and then
this was like oh we're gonna do eight
nine and ten and it rushed she literally
turns around and she's the Scarlet Witch
I understand that the end of one
division she was becoming the Scarlet
Witch but she wasn't yet so when she
literally pivots and goes evil it feels
like a bad comic book delivery it feels
like I missed some issues so between
that and some of the editing choices in
rushing certain things I would love to
see a two hour and 40 minute version of
what Sam Raimi made because I love the
Sam Raimi movie in here and I enjoyed
the horror in here it's some of my
favorite visual horror elements in the
greater MCU the cloak is incredible some
of the beautiful zombie moments are way
more exciting and more for me than I
would have expected the 90s overlap fade
montages all exceptional there's a lot
here that works but when things don't
like America Chavez stepping on an
exposition machine and being told her
history that I can't I can't put that
higher than this so unfortunately these
two films back to back are on the lower
side coming in at number 15 seen the
first of the live action shows of this
rigmarole is Hawkeye Hawkeye is a
character I love dearly Hawkeye is a
character that I love specifically in
the Run they based us off of the
fraction aha run Kate Bishop is one of
my favorite new characters in the MCU
I'm a giant fan of her I think the Haley
Steinfeld casting is immaculate I think
that Jeremy Renner getting more time to
shine as Hawkeye is so needed I loved
getting more Linda Cardellini I loved so
much about this show but I loved the
other shows more and the ending I did
not feel like this stuck the landing and
that's a flaw that Marvel had to the
point where it did come up in She-Hulk I
do think that this was one of the
examples that She-Hulk referenced I do
think that there were things that
absolutely were incredible in this and
that's what's interesting about these
lists is I love the greater MCU so even
the things I don't enjoy the the three
we've said so far they're still in that
CC minus range for me which is still a
bell curve average this is like a B
minus this is still something I think is
better than a lot of things but
something has to be lower and because of
the ending because of what it did with
Kingpin because of some of the rushed
exposition to get to action because of
some of the rush Exposition there were
some moments that I was like man this
isn't quite there it's very close still
a high B minus but it is what it is
Hawkeye's number 15. number 14 a
She-Hulk She-Hulk is very interesting in
that a lot of the time I struggle with
the third Act of MCU a lot of the time I
think like man the second act of this
and most of the First Act is just Aces
it's crushing it I think that's genius
they acknowledge that in She-Hulk I
think She-Hulk is overall very funny
very inventive very witty I'm not
putting it this this spot because of CGI
because that is a part of the puzzle
absolutely but with the pandemic with
with everything it juggled I am going
hey I'm gonna give a little asterisk
there I understand that you're inventing
a new type of character in a different
way we'd had the models for Abomination
for Hulk we've had different character
sets where those that CGI could look
different so that isn't as big of the
deal for me it's when a joke is a joke
for the sake of a joke that feels like
it's doing it at me instead of with me
when I feel like it's going like haha I
want to be with them on this journey and
I love the twist at the end so much so
that I forgive a lot of that but there
were some episodes in the middle of this
that even with knowing the twist did
feel like they fell flat comedically
because they were looking for the joke
instead of looking for the character
development instead of looking for the
evolution of the MCU instead of looking
at what rules that actually could be
born of this this is a lawyer show we
barely got any law this is something
that really could have set a precedent
for comedic lawyering to grow out what
the rules of the ncu are but instead a
lot of the time it was like joke joke
joke joke cool scene joke joke so the
first two in the last two episodes
absolutely incredible I think it's the
opposite of most third act problems I
love the ending of this the middle
sagged a bit so it's a little lower
we've got another show coming in at
number 13 and that is the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier I'm very curious about
where the show ends up Landing overall
because now we're into the Beast we're
out of the b-minuses into the bees and I
think with thunder bolts and I think
with time this one might get even higher
this is a show that I don't think people
realized how riveting it was week to
week there's certain episodes that blew
up the internet I think the The Shield
moment was one of the most impactful
moments in the MCU I think some of the
speeches in here I think Baron zimo
dancing I think there's a lot that
really was impactful I think it gathered
that Espionage tone I think seeing you
know our white wolf in Bucky Barnes uh
with the dorm Elijah it was really
impactful I seen these characters go to
therapy when the entire phase four is
about what it is to go through trauma
these are very important moments but
there were a few things you know that
that did fall apart like the villains
had to get Rewritten and excised because
their plot was based around a virus and
a vaccine there were moments where I was
like why is Baron Zemo this chill with
these guys he is a villain they had to
do some creative you know suspension
from disbelief sometimes it didn't work
a lot of times it did I think the show
is better than people remember I think
this show is a great way to do action
with a TV budget I think it evolved both
Bucky and our new Captain America very
very well gave us great supporting and
characters that we're gonna see again in
Captain America four and I'm really
excited for all that but until I see
where asiah Bradley goes until I see
what lands at the Eli Bradley and these
other characters it's on the middle of
my overall Journey but I enjoyed it
quite a bit all right next up we've got
Moon Knight now Moon Knight is an
interesting one because it is all of the
problems that shulk demonstrated the the
third act issues and the final episode
being you know a punch month but when it
worked it worked so well I loved Ethan
Hawke here I think Oscar Isaac's acting
maybe some of the best acting in the MCU
I think what Oscar Isaac was able to do
riveting us for six episodes of just
incredible psychological acting and
action what they were able to do with
the characters on what these three
directors Justin Aaron Mohammed were
able to do with this world they were
able to build a tapestry of religion and
backstory and and future story and
psychology and this uh this Cult of
Personality they were able to do all
these things while Khan shoes running
around looking incredible while you have
hippopotamus Gods running around that
feel like yeah that's that's totally a
thing it was able to suspend the
disbelief in ways I didn't think were
possible I didn't think kanji would look
like I could reach out and touch him I
didn't think I could run into Concho in
a back alley now I feel like that
reality so it's got to get points for
that if the last episode didn't turn
into a punch mop I think this would be
very high on my list I did feel the
ending didn't quite grab me but overall
Moon Knight did a lot right and I feel
like that is due to the trust that this
show had in its audience and that's the
main thing that I love about it is they
let the creators and the filmmakers make
something that trusted us and that's
really beautiful and I loved it all
right now back to movies we've got black
widow now admittedly I'm one of the few
people that got to see this in the
theater I will completely own that might
have enhanced my experience but this is
one of the ones I don't understand the
hate behind uh this movie was Jason
Bourne with black widow like I wanted
this movie gave me some incredible Red
Room sequences this movie gave me some
brutal action this movie introduced us
to Florence Pew as our new black widow
this movie gave us David Harper's red
Guardian this movie gave us a beautiful
send-off for our Black Widow now there
are things I don't like I did not like
the Taskmaster being mechanized and not
having powers but basically just using
you know computerized version of powers
that didn't work for me I didn't like
the Taskmaster was mute either I didn't
mind her being a woman but I did mind
that she didn't have all of the
snarkiness of Taskmaster because that's
all dialogue based and they got rid of
that but when it was working the opening
clean sequence with David Harbor Rachel
Weiss taking off that incredible
sequence that lays you into this film
genius the twists and turns with racial
Weiss the things they were able to do in
making David Harbor this guy that you
shouldn't like but man he's so Charming
you're in and again the action set
pieces I personally got a whole lot out
of Black Widow but I'll totally own the
first time I saw it was in a theater and
that really enhanced my experience as I
always say a movie theater is the best
way to watch these movies or shows just
see it as big and loud as you can I will
always hold that black widow experience
as a very very special one to me so it's
in that solid B approach plus range all
right we're into the top 10 and now
under the solid b-plus territory we've
got the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special this
was magic this was what you love about
the holidays this was that feeling of
family and sentimentality this was that
warm fuzzy this was the guardian so
they're characters that you can't help
but love this was a showcase for the
side characters we haven't gotten to
spend as much time with we know we love
Drax it's good to get him as our co-lead
we haven't had nearly enough time with
mantis until this I love that Palm
clemtoff got her I think that's how you
pronounce her name Palm Clint off got
her time to shine because she's so
genius such a unique force in comedy and
she's able to do so much here then you
add that Kevin Bacon magic not only is
Kevin Bacon playing Kevin Bacon but you
see the transition of Kevin Bacon when
he's manipulated when he's not and then
you get to see Kevin Bacon sing you get
to have a fish out of water Kevin Bacon
while he's brainwashed you get to have
Kevin Bacon playing uh exaggerate you
get so much Kevin Bacon you get like
five pounds of Kevin Bacon you get an
excess of bacon all of that with some
flashbacks to yondu so we feel that
again which I loved that they were in
anime that way we don't feel like they
sacrificed you know Michael rooker's
last appearance being so powerful I
loved that we got the evolution of these
characters I love that they use Michael
Rooker in animation and I love that that
didn't devalue anything I also really
appreciate that all of this felt like it
was a continuation but it wasn't married
into anything so much so that you had to
watch all the MCU again I feel like I'm
gonna watch this a lot of Christmases I
feel like it's authentically a Christmas
movie special what have you and I also
feel that all of the warm fuzzies I got
and all the laughs I got were so well
earned because of these characters that
we've grown up with we've had the
Guardians for so long and I I really got
a lot out of this it was a really
special special number nine I'm going
with Miss Marvel Miss Marvel was really
fun if you watch this channel which I
assume you do because you're here if you
don't subscribe hit that notification
Bell we had such a good time watching
this show together and this was one of
my favorite experiences working with
reject nation is you guys were so
responsive we got to experience what
your experience of this was and we all
learned stuff like I really like when
comic books can teach me while they're
entertaining me one of my favorite
things about Miss Marvel is she always
felt like the modern silver age
Spider-Man now that's a very important
distinction there are different chapters
of every character's history Silver age
Spider-Man is very much innocent
protecting his town very uh you know
friendly neighborhood very contained but
you learned about Peter and his
relationships Miss Marvel feels like
that for the modern day to me you care
about Circle Q you care about her
friends you love her family and in this
case you're learning about the Muslim
culture I knew so little about Muslim
culture and I got to learn so much
because of the comic books I got to
learn even more here I learned about you
know the the coming down of the wall in
India I learned about certain
relationships that I never knew existed
and that's because you know I grew in
public school and I love that a thing
that is so spectacular so investing so
overwhelming can also educate so not
only is it entertaining not only is it
funny not only does it refer to things
not only does it give it the first
mutants like that drop by the way was
insane that's definitely a moment in MTU
history when we heard that sound cue you
but it did all of that while informing
educated and growing us as people and
there's nothing better than when
entertainment makes you a better person
by educating you so miss Marvel's a very
very special place in my heart and that
experience of watching it I'll always
remember number eight is tricky because
it's like five minutes but it's also so
perfect in its five minutes I didn't
know how to include this in any other
list because it is so short but it is
like those Pixar animated shorts in that
you want no less you want as much of it
as you can and you love every
millisecond I am Groot is Pitch Perfect
you are madly in love with this
character throughout you care about his
hijinks you're invested in the world
everyone they introduce is immediately
important you're so endeared to every
scenario this is what animation can be
and honestly this shows that it's not
just the connectivity via looking into
an actor's eyes that put what if where
it did because spoiler alert groot's not
real and I felt so much for Groot and I
am Groot and it did it so quickly this
is something that I watched and I
remember consciously with each episode
going man I can't wait to have kids and
show them this I love that so much of
what I love is something I can share
with my kids when I have them I am Groot
specifically like I don't have kids
right now but when I do that's like a
year two thing like that's very soon I
love how accessible the MCU is I love
how beautifully available this series is
and I really love that they're mixing up
the formula this is minutes and it's so
encompassing versus three hours of end
game versus three hours of eternals
there's so much here and it's like that
and I love when you can you can play
with mediums and I think I am Groot is
there's nothing I'd change it's perfect
all right right from one special to a
special edition we're going werewolf by
night is number seven this one was hard
we're now into the A's any of this can
change I am groots the first a any of
this could kind of Juggle around it just
didn't feel fair to give something
that's only a few minutes as high a
ranking as stuff that endured and took
years to make World by night is also
minute to minute perfect I would change
nothing I love the action I love the
drama I love how immediately we are
invested in characters that don't always
even work in the comic books Elsa
Bloodstone is a character that I like
but I never would be like oh that's
someone I'm gonna read everything she's
ever done Elsa Bloodstone is a fun
concept of a character she's a good duet
uh says Machina but she's not like I'm
gonna follow the exploits and Elsa
Bloodstone now I care because of this
actor is just crushing it immediately I
like werewolf by night but I've never
sought him out but because of what they
were able to do I want to know more of
his side Adventures when something can
get a comic fan to be more of a comic
fan you know it's exceptional add to
that this is Michael giaccino's
directorial debut of something of this
scale add to that that he scores all of
these Incredible movies and did all of
that while making this the guy was
scoring the Batman and making wearup by
night that's incredible so it is a
abundance of riches and on top of all
that it gives this bad thing it gives us
I would argue one of the best practical
meet CGI characters since Jurassic
freaking part man thing looks like
someone you can hug if you want to be
you also know we can kill you I that's
the character I want more of Ted give me
a man thing movie tomorrow because of
this and on top of all that it was bold
it was black and white it felt like a
period piece it felt like a universal
monster movies experience this
authentically felt like it could have
been from the 30s the 60s or today and I
just love I don't know I I could do an
hour on this I love this experience it's
an egg it's great it's number seven it's
wear off by Night top six and where it
gets hard for me to talk about it in
brief chongqi was for me in all of the
best ways oh my God they can still make
me feel that phase one magic we hear so
many movies into the MCU and this was an
origin movie and I was enamored I love
when they're able to skip over the
origin if we already know it if I ever
see pearls again in regards to Batman
it'll be too soon I also love when they
can show me that origin movies can fit
in seamlessly into an already
established universe and I think shanxi
is arguably the best origin movie post
phase one it is everything you want from
a character that is going to be
shouldering a franchise it is charm it
is action it is comedy it is
effortlessness when simu Liu walked on
stage at Hall h i was like that is a
movie star right there that's that's a
movie star and then this came out two
years later and it was like yes it is
then you've got Aquafina doing
incredible supporting work you've got
all of these Incredible characters that
you immediately care about and you've
just met them you also bring back a
Twist that I personally loved but a lot
of people didn't and retroactively make
it better with Ben Kingsley you
introduce an entire New World in the
third Act of this where dragons feel
plausible and you have one of the best
villains in the entire MCU I think Tony
Leung in this is up there with any of
the great villains if you watch my
villain video you see where I rank them
it is so impactful there's so much
pathos there's so much empathy there's
so much of where you understand where
he's coming from but he's still
terrifying and this is a movie based off
a comic book that literally had Fu
Manchu and magic rings they bring the
tent rings to life in a very literal way
and I guarantee those 10 rings are going
to be essential going forward I think
they title eternals I think they tied a
Kang I think they tied in this Marvel
all of that in An Origin movie with
maybe the best soundtrack there's just
so much um Black Panther and chunky
either way I could talk about shangshi
again it's getting harder because we're
getting into my faves but shanxi Pitch
Perfect uh I wouldn't change anything
and one of the best theater experiences
I've ever had alright we are into the
top five now I'm gonna be totally honest
with you this and shangshi were tied I
was like either one of these could be
five I honest honestly it depends on my
mood but this one gets the edge because
of spite because of the disrespect it
received because I feel like someone
needs to fight this battle so it
literally edged out because I I need to
acknowledge the importance of this a
turtle's phone owns eternals is so good
eternals is the kind of movie I've been
wanting the MCU to make to show people
hey it is not just Cape stuff this is a
movie that is about evolution of mankind
this is a movie about the choices we
make as people this is a movie having
Gods be fallible and be so fallible that
we relate to them as humans while they
do things that are so human that the
Lesser humanoid animals that we also
realize are humanoid in a second act
twist are conflicting much like humans
do whilst they end up making a choice
that effectively makes them villains
there is so much philosophy here we have
characters that decide billions of lives
are worth sacrificing for our lives they
make the most selfish Choice that's a
villain move it's the anti knows Thanos
was literally like we need to preserve
Life by killing half and the the
eternals are like we need to save these
people oh no deal with it fascinating I
love all of this I also love that my
experience with it means I can have
these long conversations with people I
love that my personal experience is that
there are scenes where you don't see
like three of the characters and when
they come back I immediately know how
they're going to react to this situation
because I know them so well and I just
met them this is the movie that showed
me a team movie and one can work this is
a movie that showed me I can be just as
invested in druig as I am in Thor I can
be so invested in these characters just
as quickly as the characters I've been
riding with for 14 years that's insane
in its accomplishment plus it's so
beautiful plus the third act action is
so uh riveting while not feeling tonally
different from the drama this movie has
been eternals does not get enough love
it is a masterpiece it is so special
I've literally done interviews about
this I've been on Rotten Tomatoes as
wrong to the point where Chloe how we
shared me yelling about how good this
movie was because I think this is the
thing that I'm seeing in a way that when
we look at it in five years other people
I hope see it in the same way I hope
that the way I experience it is the way
other people experience it in time I
personally cannot wait to watch it in
the greater tapestry when we find out
how it ties in and even by itself it is
so special love eternals
I also had a great debate about it it's
Greg's favorite all right top four and
bringing us to what just came out in
theaters wakanda forever wakanda forever
is a really interesting one because I
don't think I'll watch it as often
because of how much it impacted me it is
a movie that strength is that it was so
overwhelming that it's a struggle
wakanda forever is a movie that uses
sorrow in a way that makes you feel the
way the characters feel on screen
because you are relating to both
Chadwick and t'challa simultaneously it
it uses your real emotions as a tool
like you're a color on the paintbrush
you yourself are a color being used to
make this art and that is incredible and
so interesting this movie uses silence
as a weapon this movie mixes up insane
Sight and Sound with pure serene
painful silence if it was used in a
different way it'd be Serene because
it's peaceful the sound of wind on a
beach is usually about peace and instead
here it's about sorrow and absence I
love that nothing is more linear than
the absence of sound for the feeling of
absence when you get in an elevator you
are uncomfortable when there's silence
and no one talks because that's what
elevators are they're uncomfortable but
here that's used poignantly here they
weaponize silence in a way that you feel
so much for everyone and that's in a
score by ludwigorenson that is in a
movie that uses sound so effectively
that's in a movie where they had to
rewrite an entire experience and make
this work in a year and pay homage to
their actual friend that they lost this
movie is so special this movie is like
nothing else in the MCU and this movie
is what a blockbuster can be again when
you trust your audience and I think it's
really special and it's also so
impactful the maturation of the viewers
watching you know this is we've lived
with these characters and these people
for so long I I think this movie is only
going to grow in in the importance of of
what we can do in this genre it's a
really special film all right top three
you lovelies we got one division one
division is
so close to perfect and I I had it lower
for a long time because of the ending
but the more I think about it the more I
realize it was juggling being a
philosophical quandary wrapped in an
action show and that is no small task I
I really for a long time blamed its
final episode on the creators making
something that was like Marvel instead I
realized wait this is a Marvel show they
probably needed to make something more
accessible to get us to the point where
we can have a counter forever they
needed to make something more accessible
so we can trust them to make things like
Loki season two which I think is going
to be more bananas than Loki season one
I think the end of one division is not
how I wanted it to be but now I
understand why it needed to be that we
still got the ship of Theseus I don't
love that we went from the ship of
Theseus what is Vision Two punch punch
punch but I get it when you make these
properties there is a need for some of
that so now that we've done it and now
that we've made fun of it in She-Hulk
now that we've shown we don't need it in
certain things I do think we won't have
to do that again but at the time this
was the first phase four property we
just left endgame so my biggest flaw of
one division is the last episode I've
almost completely been like that's
actually okay the perks are innumerable
there's no way to list all the perks
Agatha Harkness what they were able to
do with changing time zones and the
manipulation of reality what they were
able to do week to week using the
of a thing that didn't yeah this was the
Marvel show there was no such thing as
Marvel TV to the scale they made us
every week the best marketing ever by
making us go is it Mephisto they played
us we were much like wakanda Forever
part of the paint on that art we got to
be vexed week to week and wonder what
was going on I loved that not only that
but we got to see the relationship
between a character that's an Android
and a witch be some of the best love
story I've ever seen we got to see a
villain that was effectively trauma this
early into the phase four being about
trauma and it bookends what kind of
forever beautifully because one of these
people deals with trauma aggressively
and does wrong things that turns her
into a villain skip some steps but turns
into a villain the other learns from
that Vengeance and grows in wakanda
Forever they're beautiful bookends to
phase four they they have that whole Arc
by like stacking them at the end of the
the comic shelf together I think one
division Immaculate plus some fun twists
and turns plus some beautiful
cinematography plus you know some new
characters getting to start you know
here I I really love one division it's
very special solid a plus number two and
the only thing that could have possibly
overtaken long form Marvel Loki Loki did
all of the things I just described with
one division sort of you know Agatha
Harkness and details but the ending
stuck for me this is the best last
episode of Marvel for me having the last
beats of action be verbal the the fact
that he who remains is a Shakespearean
almost puckish character any monologue
so impactfully that not only do you care
about Jonathan Majors now not only are
you fascinated by Kang but you've just
had this entire action show that is
largely about Concepts Beyond
understanding and then you do this to
cap it off it's so tonally perfect it's
so inventive in its World building it's
so on brand for the show and it doesn't
sacrifice what weirdness we had where
half the show is two people talking
Mobius and Loki talking should not be
that riveting but we have incredible
writers who got Tom Hiddleston we got
Owen Wilson and then how how do you top
that or how do you you know have a
resolution for that you find Jonathan
majors and he remains just changes the
game I think Loki uh short of not
showing Owen Wilson on a jet ski is
perfect I honestly if they had done that
a A plus plus if they've done that maybe
they'd be number one I needed that jet
ski but it is every week so special we
can't forget OG Loki we can't forget the
first time we saw variants we can't
forget the moment we saw president Loki
fighting our Loki there's so many
moments that are like I'll never see
that in live action and it did it in a
show about the philosophy of what it
means to be a person what it means to
exist the philosophy of time it did it
in such a heady special way this show is
is my favorite show that Marvel has done
it is amongst my favorite adaptations of
anything sci-fi I've yet to watch Doctor
Who and apparently I have to because
this is very Doctor Who so it is so my
jam to a level that until this came out
I didn't know how to describe to people
what sci-fi I like because I enjoy a
Star War I enjoy you know Matrix but
that's a lot like this it's super heady
I like when sci-fi makes you look in
while it's exploding out and that is so
unique so uh really really special show
Loki is my dream number one with a
bullet and you guys I mean I every time
I say this the comments get more
aggressive and especially in the last
month there's been this two months
there's been this strange surge of no
way home hate and I won't stand for it
and I won't let it change my opinion I
don't know that as an adult I've ever
had a theatrical experience like
Spider-Man no way home I don't know that
as an adult I believed in the magic of
[ __ ] Cinema like Spider-Man no way
home this showed me that every single
thing can lead to something greater I
like the Tobey Maguire movies I used to
love them now I like them and this made
me love them again because it put it in
this beautiful context and gave me
that's a different Universe of
Spider-Man it doesn't have to be my guy
Tom Holland to me is the exact right
Spider-Man for an Avengers Universe
Andrew Garfield to me is the comic book
Spider-Man come to life now because of
the way the story is told Toby McGuire
feels so perfect for that universe that
Silver age Sam Raimi flavor that didn't
quite stick with me as an adult but I
have this new refound love for so when a
movie can make you retroactively Love
Stuff more I'm always gonna like yes and
on top of that the spider-verse
storyline in the comic books I always
felt like was an excuse to sell toys and
shirts and merch and I was like this is
fun and it brings in some of my
favorites like Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man
29.9 but then the spider verse movie
showed me no it's so much more than that
they explained quantum physics to kids
spider-verse is genius and I was like
they're never gonna be able to make that
work in live action then they gave me
almost The Sinister Six plus a spider
verse Story in live action plus they did
it while making our Spider-Man Uncle Ben
plus they gave us the Uncle Ben death
moment without me plus they gave us
power and responsibility in a way that
works effectively giving us a six movie
origin story that absolutely works with
multiple villains multiple Spider-Man
and gave us closure for not just Andrew
catching you know MJ giving him that
Gwen Stacy moment not just Tom getting
to meet his heroes in real life but also
get to have a father figure in these
guys an uncle figure and Toby getting to
not just have that Vengeance quell which
was my biggest issue with Spider-Man was
he always had an anger in him that
didn't feel he didn't grow out of it his
ark didn't didn't solve the anger I
always felt crazy that in the Tobi
Maguire Spider-Man movies he like didn't
quite deserve Mary Jane the relationship
wasn't great and he was always angry
even before he got the Venom symbiote
they addressed that and they let that
Vengeance lie he has to grow he grows in
this into the Spider-Man I always wanted
him to be all three of my Spider-Man
grow into the Spiderman I've always
wanted them to be in one movie with all
these villains I love and Redemption for
Sandman and one of the best villain
performances of all time with home Defoe
finally getting to be the Green Goblin
that fight through the building smashing
all the way through the big Sinister Six
Sinister five fight at the end all of
this all of this is why it's my number
one
my number one MCU filmed my number one
phase four film uh I know a lot of
people are like oh without the
Spider-Man gimmick it's not a gimmick
it's plot evolving it is closure for
three sets of characters it's building
out a world there's no gimmick when it's
what the story is I don't understand how
people see using characters there's
there's definitely gimmicks in comic
book movies using characters correctly
isn't a gimmick it's storytelling it's
art and that's why it's the best of
phase four and I love it very very much
and I hope you enjoyed this list those
are the 18 phase 4 properties ranked
from my experience my favorites not
saying one is best not saying 18 is
worse saying my experience of favorites
that is how I experience them let me
know how you experience them in the
comments below let me know how you would
rank them by your favorites your opinion
and let me know what you liked and
didn't like about this video let me know
what else you guys want to see just did
a big action video involving fights
definitely should have include that
Green Goblin fight totally will own that
I didn't want to overrun with Spider-Man
but I should have it was a great fight
that said I want to hear what else you
guys want in the new year and
um yeah let me know what you thought of
this video like subscribe share with
your friends we'll see you soon
[Music]